in an exclusive interview we are hearing
from two of the grand jurors in the
brianna taylor case
the 26 year old woman was shot and
killed in her own home during a
louisville police raid back in march
no police officers were charged for the
shooting taylor and at least one of the
officers involved
has defended their actions we spoke with
the jurors and their attorney who say
they were never given the option to
consider murder or manslaughter charges
that contradict statements made by the
kentucky attorney general
we are not releasing the identities of
the grand jurors at their request
for their safety can i ask you what you
both think of the police
behavior and actions that night
negligent negligent they couldn't even
provide a risk assessment
and it sounded like they hadn't done one
so their organization
leading up to this was lacking that's
what i mean by they were
negligent in in the operation
number two they were criminal leading up
to this
and everything that they the way they
moved forward on it
including the warrant was deception
yeah you can see more of our exclusive
interview with these two jurors that's
tomorrow on cbs this morning they wanted
to be called
grandeur number one and juror number two
um
but they said it was it was it was
difficult to come forward but it also
wasn't difficult because they were so
outraged when they heard
the decision they said hey they had
never met daniel cameron had no
dealings with him whatsoever and when
they heard his statement saying that
grand jury believes this
or agrees with this they said there was
outrage in the grand jury room they had
a lot of very interesting things
i'm very interested to hear what they
have to say especially as we've
discussed at this table before about the
warrant how it came about
and what the police were told when they
went to that point a lot of questions
yeah
you heard that comment about the risk
assessment yeah exactly
all right